- Valentine's Day is coming up.
Do you and Dave ever do anything
or are y'all chill about it?
- We don't really do anything.
- We don't either.
- [Alison] We don't care.
- [Kelly] I want every day
to be special, not just one.
You're not getting just one
day you have to be nice.
You know what I'm saying?
(audience applauds)
- I agree, yes.
- I would like several.
- I've always really felt,
yes, I feel like if you're
in a good relationship
and you're loving to your
partner all the time.
I feel like I'm much more
a fan of the surprise gift,
coming home on a Tuesday.
- Just a Monday night, yes.
- And there's flowers
and a little card that's like,
"I love you, I appreciate you."
Or I'll leave him, if
I'm gonna leave town,
we'll leave each other
little cards or stuff
on each other's pillow.
- That's awesome.
- All the time.
- My husband does that
all the time.
- So Valentine's Day is like oh,
I feel like we're always
at the last second,
"Oh, honey, I love you."
- [Kelly] You're great.
- Yes, and then we'll throw something.
Usually, maybe I'll cook dinner
and we'll watch a movie,
which is what we do
- Every night.
- most nights, if I'm not working, anyway.
But it has that special tinge.
- Sometimes I feel like Valentine's Day,
all it does is start fights.
- I think the only purpose
of it is to sell flowers
and greeting cards
and to get young couples
and very new couples who have
been dating a couple months
to get in a big fight.
- They're just giving you, yeah,
you're just gonna screw up.
- It's like a real test
for someone that you've been
on a handful of dates with
and you're like, what's he gonna do?
- Oh my god.
- What's he gonna do?
Did he plan something?
- I hate that pressure.